[Musique]
où
l'armistice du 11 novembre 1918 fut
accueillie dans toute l'europe comme le
point final de toutes les guerres
presque aussitôt les grandes puissance
maritime mondiale
c'est à dire la grande bretagne la
france lina celle du militarisme et donc
du réarmement
malgré les engagements pris la plupart
des gouvernements en terre de contourner
les restrictions de la conférence de
washington
l'allemagne elle n'avait pas participé à
celle ci la flotte impériale s'était
sabordé à scapa flow en 1919 et les
clauses draconiennes du traité de
versailles empêcher théoriquement toute
reconstitution
toutefois au milieu des années 30 ces
restrictions étaient plus ou moins
ouvertement tourné par le gouvernement
allemand et l'ex marine impériale se
mettaient à revivre
dans les mois précédant la guerre
hitler souligna dans ses discours
l'importance qu'il attachait un blocus
de l'angleterre en cas de conflit de son
côté l'amirauté britannique mis au point
un plan destiné à isoler le troisième
reich
la toute jeune creeks marine était
encore loin d'être au point mais son
chef le grand amiral reder avait reçu
l'assurance du führer que celui ci ne se
lancerait pas dans la guerre avant 1944
cela donnerait le temps à la flotte
d'être à la hauteur de sa rivale la
royal navy
le 1er septembre 1939 les troupes
allemandes envahir la pologne sans
déclaration de guerre
deux jours plus tard à l'expiration d'un
ultimatum laissant au reich le temps de
se retirer
la grande-bretagne entra en guerre
quelques heures plus tard l'eau 30 du
lieutenant de vaisseau lump torpillé par
erreur le transport britannique athénien
[Musique]
e
la kriegsmarine se révéla dès le début
du conflit mal préparés à la guerre les
grands navires de surface en particulier
n'était ni assez nombreux ni assez
adapté au type de combat ouvert qui vont
notamment caractérisé la bataille de
l'atlantique
la stratégie du commandement était
orientée vers le blocus de la grande
bretagne et les bâtiments étaient en
conséquence préparé à ce type
d'engagement et non bataille classiques
contre les navires alliés
la lecture du règlement de la crise
marine éclaircies parfaitement cet
aspect du conflit
certaines méthodes d' attaque ne devront
jamais être écartées sous prétexte
qu'elle pourrait être contraire aux
règlements internationaux
[Musique]
oh
on
non
[Musique]
il
le torpillage de la thénia semble à
confirmer cet état d'esprit et
l'amirauté britannique l'interpréta
comme la preuve que la guerre maritime
serait sans merci
elle abandonna aussitôt la stratégie
mise au point avant la guerre basée sur
les patrouilles et les opérations
exécutées
loin des routes marchande à sa place fut
conçu un système de convoi protégé par
des bâtiments de guerre et un blocus
parallèle du troisième reich
la bataille de l'atlantique débute sous
la forme de raids contre les navires de
ravitaillement et leur escorteur ces
combats sporadiques n'entraîne pas de
véritable bataille et n'applique pas
plus de deux ou trois bâtiments de
surface mais la responsabilité des
agressions contre les navires alliés et
neutre repose bientôt sur les seules ou
bottes de l'amiral tonix c'est à la fin
de l'année 1939 qu'ont lieu les
premières attaques de ce que l'on
appelle très vite les loups gris
ceci met au point une tactique qui leur
permet de remporter de nombreuses
victoires
aussitôt aperçu la fumée ou la
silhouette d'un navire ou d'un convoi la
meute des ou boat dispersés dans une
zone se réunie grâce à la liaison radio
et attaqua leur enfance
après celle des sous marins la menace la
plus importante est celle des mines
anglais et allemands utilisent la même
technique et mouiller ses armes
mortelles dissimulé entre deux eaux
aussi bien sur les routes
traditionnellement suivie par les
navires marchands qui à l'entrée des
ports les perdants bâtiment et en marins
sont rapidement très importante
à eux seuls les alliés ont perdu à la
fin 2009 139 plus de 250 mille tonnes
[Musique]
la première grande bataille navale a
lieu en décembre
peu de temps après le début des
hostilités la kriegsmarine a en effet
mis en place un important dispositif de
sous marins du navire de surface en mer
du nord et dans l'atlantique nord parmi
ces bâtiments le cuirassé de poche graff
super commandée par le capitaine de
vaisseau langsdorff durant tout l'hiver
1939 le graf spee opèrent contre les
navires marchands hors de la zone
couverte par les hobos à la mi-décembre
cependant après être passé dans
l'atlantique sud
il est pris en chasse par les croiseurs
britannique à qui laisse ajax est exact
est la bataille s'engage le 13 décembre
dans le rio de la plata ayant subi
d'importants dommages matériels et
humains
le graf spee se réfugie dans le port
neutre de montevideo
[Musique]
langsdorff espère s'y refaire mais les
autorités russes voyaient nuit donne le
choix entre l'internement et le départ
le port est bloqué par les vaisseaux
anglais qui attendent leur proie les
négociations diplomatiques ayant échoué
le capitaine langsdorff appareil le 17
et ce à bord de son navire avant de se
suicider le graff spe qui apparaissait
comme un bateau mythique avait cependant
révélé ses faiblesses au combat sa perte
fut pour la kriegsmarine plus moral que
matériel
la bataille de l'atlantique se poursuit
avec acharnement au début 2009 140 en
avril les allemands ont réussi à couler
239 navires marchands chiffre qui
atteindra 1059 à la fin de l'année dont
349 à l'actif des sols sous marins
la flotte de surface si elle intervient
également ne se montre pas très efficace
l'industrie de guerre allemande
entraînent de très important besoin
d'acier le faire nécessaire provient
essentiellement du nord de la suède
or le port principal d'approvisionnement
lulea est temps pris par les glaces une
partie de l'hiver les allemands
utilisent le port de narvik en norvège
malgré la neutralité de ce pays les
alliés décident d'occuper narvik afin de
couper cette fameuse route du fer
cependant conscient de l'importance
industriel et stratégique de cette
région
hitler coupe l'herbe sous le pied des
alliés
[Musique]
le 8 avril 1940
les forces allemandes lance sur les
côtes norvégiennes une opération
combinant une attaque amphibies et
aéroportée elle est soutenue de
l'intérieur par la cinquième colonne du
major vidkun quisling et de son parti
national-socialiste norvégien la réponse
des alliés rapide des troupes
franco-britanniques assisté d'une
brigade polonaise débarque à billère vic
et progresse vers narvik la rff et la
royal navy a taclé navire de la
kriegsmarine et endommagent trois
croiseurs deux autres engagements lieu
devant narvik le 10 et le 13 avril les
navires de surface poulain ou boat et 10
destroyer malgré leurs contre attaques
continuelles les sous marins de
donizetti ne peuvent toucher qu'un seul
bâtiment à lier leurs torpilles
défectueuse n'obtiennent par les
résultats attendus
[Musique]
oh
on
à terre les chasseurs de montagne du
général d'ides elles ont plus de succès
et la situation en belgique et en france
entraîne le 27 avril
l'évacuation du corps expéditionnaire
les allemands peuvent ainsi resserrer
leur emprise sur la norvège mais la
kriegsmarine ne se relèvera jamais
complètement des pertes de narvik et
entre en guerre contre les alliés et le
22 la france signe l'armistice avec le
reich qui va pouvoir ainsi disposer des
bases maritimes et aériennes françaises
pour opérer dans l'atlantique avec les
condors de la luftwaffe et les sous
marins de devenir l'une des clauses de
cet armistice est également lourd de
conséquences
la marine française doit en effet être
interné dans ses propres ports craignant
que ces puissants et splendide bâtiment
soit utilisée par les forces de l' axe
contre les alliés
le gouvernement britannique souhaiterait
que les navires présents dans les ports
d'afrique du nord soit désarmé devant le
refus de vichy les vaisseaux anglais
n'hésite pas le 3 juillet 1940 à ouvrir
le feu sur la flotte ancrés dans le port
de mers-el-kébir coulant plusieurs
unités en endommageant d'autres et tuant
de nombreux marins la royal navy a ainsi
écrit une nouvelle page sanglants de
l'histoire navale franco britannique
l'entrée de l'italie dans la guerre
change immédiatement le rapport des
forces en méditerranée sa position
géographique et le contrôle des ports
libyens lui permettent de déployer ses
forces à l'est ou à l'ouest en fonction
des nécessités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la royal navy est donc obligé de
répartir ces unités entre alexandrie et
gibraltar
si des escarmouches opposent parfois les
deux adversaires
les italiens ne recherche pas
l'affrontement avec les anglais ils ne
tiennent pas réellement les accès de
l'atlantique de suez
[Musique]
ma personne
mussolini pratique une stratégie
essentiellement défensive
il ordonne cependant le minage du
détroit de sicile obligeant ainsi le
trafic méditerranéen à passer à travers
un étroit chenal facilement contrôlé par
les sous marins et les patrouilles
aériennes
cela gêne considérablement le
ravitaillement des garnisons britannique
du moyen-orient et nécessite la
protection de tous les convois marchand
le 13 septembre 1940 les troupes
italiennes attaques dans l'égypte leur
avance est stoppé par la résistance
britannique qui manquant de
ravitaillement et de munitions voit du
même coup sa puissance de feu diminuer
le matériel et les munitions de l'armée
anglaise doivent en effet passer par le
cap au sud de l'afrique afin d'éviter la
marine italienne qui guette en
méditerranée le long délai nécessaire
pour couvrir une pareille distance a des
conséquences désastreuses en plein
combat
le cabinet de londres doit trouver une
solution
celle qui va être retenu va changer le
cours de la guerre
[Musique]
au matin du 11 novembre 1941 des navires
de guerre britannique escortant un
convoi destiné à malte font route vers
la mer ionienne
le voyage se déroule sans incident la
flotte italienne comprenant six navires
de bataille est à l'ancré dans le port
de tarente à 9 heures du soir plusieurs
escadrille de bombardiers d'école du
porte-avions illustrious et se dirige
vers le port italien
deux heures plus tard tarente est en
flammes non seulement ces installations
portuaires
mais les réservoirs de carburant le
fracas des bombes et bientôt relayé par
les explosions des torpilles sur les
coques des navires à l'anc
une seconde vague de bombardier arrive à
minuit
lorsqu'elle est passée 3 cuirassé et
deux croiseurs gisent fortement
endommagé il faudra plusieurs mois pour
les remettre en état et l'un d'entre eux
ne naviguera plus jamais
[Musique]
vous
depuis le milieu de l'été la bataille
d'angleterre tenait la grande bretagne
sous la menaces continuelles des
attaques aériennes dans l'atlantique
léo boat couler de nombreux bâtiments
marchand l'invasion de la grèce par
l'italie à la guerre en afrique du nord
poser de graves problèmes de
ravitaillement aux alliés dans un tel
contexte la victoire de tarente revêtait
une importance particulière
la mise hors de combat de la moitié du
corps de bataille navale italien
réduisait la menace pesant sur les
convois en méditerranée et permettait
aux alliés de renforcer leurs positions
à malte et en egypte
[Musique]
la rente et non seulement la première
victoire alliée depuis la chute de la
france mais au delà il faut voir la
stratégie qui a été appliquée pour
l'obtenir
depuis lépante en 1571 les canons de
gros calibre ont toujours joué un rôle
déterminant dans toutes les grandes
batailles navales
les navires de guerre lancée après la
première guerre mondiale sont pour la
plupart un compromis entre un puits sans
armement et un blindage non moins
puissants avec l'entrée du porte-avions
sur le champ de bataille s'ouvre une
nouvelle ère de la guerre navale
[Musique]
les événements méditerranée sont suivis
avec attention par de nombreux
observateurs
à l'autre bout du monde notamment les
experts de la flotte japonaise impériale
ont étudié dans le détail la bataille de
tarente eux aussi souhaitent pouvoir
détruire un adversaire sans avoir à
affronter les périls d'un engagement
maritimes classiques la bataille de
tarente devient pour eux un modèle dont
ils vont s'inspirer pour concevoir leur
futur plan d' attaque
à la fin 2009 140 l'effort de guerre de
l'italie est durement touché ses troupes
recul en afrique du nord et piétinent en
grèce
les forces alliées basé à malte cause
des pertes sévères aux convois de lax et
en janvier 1941 la luftwaffe et
l'aviation italienne lance plusieurs
attaques commune pour neutraliser lille
[Musique]
en février les troupes de rommel arrivé
en libye et leur présence va changer le
sort de la bataille en faveur de lax
elle va aussi accroître l'intérêt des
allemands pour le front méditerranée
si bien que lorsque les britanniques
envoient d'un important convoi de
renforts de troupes vers la grèce sans
que la marine italienne interviennent
hitler envoie mussolini une demande
pressante pour que ses troupes et ses
d'intercepter les navires anglais
le 27 mars une force navale italienne
importante
commandé par l'amiral iñaki nos
découvertes par le 10ème corps aérien
allemand part à la recherche du convoi
dans le secteur de la crète les
bâtiments anglais sous les ordres de
l'amiral cunningham ont quitté
alexandrie dans la nuit et à l'aube du
les deux navires amiraux sont au contact
devant le cap matap al les croiseurs
britannique manoeuvre sous le feu dans
l'espoir d'attirer leurs adversaires
sous leurs propres batteries
[Musique]
mais le commandant de la flotte
italienne flers le piège et rompant le
combat il met le cap à l'ouest les
navires italiens réussissent dans un
premier temps à fuir mais dans
l'après-midi le croiseur vittorio veneto
qui porte la marque de l'amiral
giacchino est gravement endommagée par
les avions torpilleurs du formidable
à la nuit tombée
le croiseur ajax ayant repéré
l'adversaire au radar
les anglais ouvre le feu est cool les
deux croiseurs fiume aidara de
torpilleurs le quart ducci et l'algérie
et deux destroyers un troisième croiseur
sévèrement atteints est abandonné par
son équipage qui reviendra à bord
quelques heures plus tard de nombreux
marins ont été intoxiqués par des
vapeurs toxiques venue de la salle des
machines et décale dans lesquels étaient
entreposés du vin
le croiseur sera rattrapé par les
anglais et torpillé la perte de ces gros
bâtiments réduits sensiblement les
possibilités d'interception de convois
de la marine italienne
le 6 avril la wehrmacht en veille la
grèce et le 11 le président américain
franklin roosevelt et crds est une zone
de défense
s'étendant de l'islande à l'afrique
occidentale
l'objectif est de renforcer la
protection du trafic maritime alliés
notamment contre les sous marins de la
kriegsmarine les violations de cette
zone mèneront bientôt à l'entrée en
guerre des etats unis le 21 mai 1941 le
cuirassé bismarck portant la marque de
l'amiral hulot tiennent ce kit la mer de
norvège accompagné du croiseur lourd
brienz eigen pour une campagne contre
les convois repéré par les britanniques
les deux bâtiments sont prises en chasse
par les croiseurs sauf allik et norfolk
auxquels se joignent bientôt venant de
scapa flow les croiseurs houde et prince
of wales ainsi que quatre destroyers la
bataille s'engage à l'eau du 24 mai et
dès les premières salves le bismarck
endommage gravement le prince of wales
et cool le good portant la marque de
l'amiral hollande mais le bismarck
avariée rond le combat ait fui vers
saint nazaire poursuivi par le sol
qu'est le norfolk auxquels se joignent
plusieurs navires dont le porte-avions
victorious et le croiseur king george 5
attaqué par les avions du victorious les
25 et 26 mai le bismarck est fortement
touchée par leurs torpilles
la bataille se poursuit dans la nuit
contre les destroyers et au matin du 27
mai le bismarck disparaît sous le feu du
king george 5 du rouennais et du dorset
shy il n'y aura que 110 survivants sur
les 2200 marins et officiers d'olhain d
orgueil de la kriegsmarine
[Musique]
durant tout l'été les ou boat continuent
à traquer les convois alliés dans
l'atlantique roulant soixante et un
navires en juin et 23 en juillet la
situation est de plus en plus tendues
entre les forces de l' axe et les états
unis après un nouvel incident septembre
entre lou 652 commandés par le
lieutenant de vaisseau frat et le
destroyer grrr un capitaine de corvette
frost le président roosevelt lance son
ordre fameux aux forces navales
américaines de la zone ouest tirer à vue
malgré cela les sous-marins poursuivent
leurs agressions en novembre le porte
avions britannique ark royal écoulée
parent ou bottes à 25000 de malte et le
croiseur australien sydney est victime
d'un raider allemand bâtiments de
commerce armée en guerre et naviguant
sous pavillon hollandais
le 26 du même mois la flotte japonaise
appareils la guerre navale entre dans
une nouvelle phase
elle sera sans merci
[Musique]
le 2 décembre alors que les négociations
diplomatiques entre les etats-unis et le
japon battent leur plein la flotte
japonaise du pacifique reçoit un message
codé
gravissez le monde n'y a qu'à deux jours
plus tard un second message parvienne à
toutes les ambassades japonaise de par
le monde
coup de vent sur l'est qui signifie
l'état de guerre imminent entre
washington et tokyo
à l'aube du 7 décembre 1941 après
plusieurs mois d'entraînement intensif
les équipages de l'aéronavale japonaise
se prépare à décoller du pont de six
porte avions de la force navale commandé
par l'amiral nagumo
[Musique]
à 6 heures du matin heure locale les
premières vagues des 183 bombardiers en
piqué avions torpilleurs et chasseurs 0
attaque
[Musique]
à
s'inspirant de la tacc de la royal navy
sur 40 les japonaises pertes anéantir la
flotte américaine du pacifique en un
seul
peu après 8h le leader des appareils
nippon lance dans son micro le cri tora
tora tora
ces formations que les guetteurs
américains n'ont pas détecté arrive en
vue de pearl harbor base principale de
la flotte us dans le pacifique
[Musique]
en quelques minutes le port est submergé
par des milliers de bombes et de
torpilles les bases aériennes voisines
sont mitraillés empêchant ainsi toute
riposte des pilotes américains comme à
tarente la première vague est suivie
d'une seconde
les 360 appareils japonais engagés dans
cette app surprise détruisent 15 navires
de guerre et 159 avions les pertes
humaines sont également très importantes
avec 2334 civils et militaires tués et
plus de 1300 blessés
[Musique]
pour
il est
[Musique]
le drame de pearl harbor s'il prive
temporairement les états unis des moyens
suffisants pour affronter le japon dans
le pacifique est stratégiquement une
erreur les trois principaux partis
avions us le saratoga l'enterprise et le
lexington étant alors en mer aucun
n'avait été touché
quant au bâtiment coulé dans les eaux
peu profondes du port ils vont pour la
plupart être renfloué les japonais
avaient réussi ce que craignait le plus
l'un de leurs principaux chefs
militaires l'amiral yamamoto réveiller
un géant
jusqu alors endormi l'alliance entre les
puissances de l'axé le japon entraîné la
guerre totale avec les états unis qui
sortant de leur isolement vont orienter
leur effort de guerre vers la production
d'armes
les craintes de yamamoto vont être
renforcés par les paroles de winston
churchill le destin d'hitler et celle et
celui de mussolini également quant aux
japonais ils seront réduits en poudre 1
[Musique]
à la même époque les japonais lance
leurs forces sur la thaïlande et la
malice mme cette conquête nippone sur
terre correspond à l'extension de sa
domination sur mer trois jours après
pearl harbor les cuirassés britannique
'prince of wales et répulse sont coulés
dans le sud de la mer de chine avec de
nombreux bâtiments à liée aux débuts de
1942 les japonais contrôle manille et se
prépare à attaquer les indes orientales
hollandaise la guerre navale se
généralise et les alliés sont incapables
de s'opposer à la flotte japonaise
[Musique]
en février 1942 les avions de l'empiré
du soleil levant pic sur l'australie et
le 19 de ce mois
ils bombardent le port de darwin le
contrôle des innombrables si les
territoires du pacifique dépend
complètement de celui des océans
japonaise et américains en sont
persuadés tout comme ils sont certains
que ce contrôle ne pourrait être assuré
que si la flotte ennemie est anéanti
[Musique]
la volonté des japonais renforcée par
les attaques lancées par les américains
contre plusieurs villes à partir de
porte avions de combat l'effet
psychologique sur l'opinion publique est
considérable et détermine l'amirauté
japonaise à affronter l'us navy dans une
bataille qui mènera sa destruction
[Musique]
contrôlant singapour et avançant en
birmanie les japonais s'intéresse
maintenant aux îles salomon et à port
moresby en nouvelle guinée
la relative proximité entre ce dernier
port et l'australie devrait pousser les
américains intervenir le plan des
japonais est simple attendent leurs
adversaires avec une force composée de
porte-avions et de troupes de
débarquement qui prendront les bâtiments
américains en tenaille et les détruirons
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard les appareils de
reconnaissance des porte avions japonais
entrer dans la mer de corail repère un
croiseur et un porte-avions qu'ils
identifient comme faisant partie de la
flotte américaine
les héros attaque mais les bâtiments ne
sont en réalité qu'un destroyers et un
pétrolier
au même moment plusieurs croiseur
américain le fonds sera plein machine
pour intercepter la flotte japonaise en
route pour port moresby
ils sont bientôt attaquer par des avions
nippon venant de la base de rabot
quant au porte avions japonais il se
retrouve isolé la plupart de leurs
appareils étant en l'air
les erreurs d'identification ne sont pas
le fait des seuls japonais les
observateurs américains aussi confondre
un après midi un groupe de croiseurs et
de destroyers ennemis avec des croiseurs
et des porte avions
les appareils ios d'école du
porte-avions york times sur cette fausse
information
mais ont la chance de rencontrer en
route un autre porte avions le show à
21h33 un message de victoires retenti
dans la salle d'opération du up down
le show et par le fonds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le matin suivant la flotte américaine
tombe dans le piège
mais la perte du show a privé les
japonais de l'une des pinces de la
tenaille leurs plans ne peut plus être
exécuté les troupes d'invasion de port
moresby doivent être retirés
deux porte avions continuaient à
patrouiller dans la mer de corail les
deux flottes sont maintenant séparés par
120 mille chasseurs américains et 0
japonais lance simultanément leurs
attaques plus rapide
les américains arrivent les premiers sur
leurs cibles et parviennent à couler les
deux porte avions japonais ceux des
américains sont également touchés
notamment le lexington gravement
endommagée par quatre torpilles et qui
finit par couler à la fin de la journée
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la guerre navale de flotte se sont
affrontés sans même s'apercevoir les
américains ont perdu un porte avion de
grande taille
alors que les japonais ne déplore que
celle d'un porte-avions d'escort mais
pour ces derniers il s'agit d'une
victoire à la pyrrhus
ils ont en effet perdu de nombreux
pilotes expérimentés ont abandonné leurs
plans d'invasion et doivent retirer deux
autres porte-avions du service les
conséquences de cette journée vont jouer
un rôle important dans le tournant de la
guerre du pacifique
[Musique]
une fois passées les événements de la
mer de corail les japonais qui ne
s'avouent pas battus se penche une
nouvelle fois sur la destruction de la
flotte américaine
leur objectif est cette fois ci la tôle
de milou et qui une fois prix
constituerait une base lointaine pour
attaquer la côte ouest des états unis
hawaii et même le canal de panama
les américains mettent bientôt lille en
état de défense l'amiral yamamoto
conçoit un nouveau plan d'invasion
dès le début les estimations des
japonais sur la puissance des forces
américaines sont fausses
les conclusions tirées des opérations de
la mer de corail leur font penser que le
seul porte avions us non coulée est hors
service pour plusieurs mois
mais si le yorkton avait en effet été
gravement touché et si les américains
eux mêmes estimé 90 jours nécessaires
pour le remettre en état
il nous faudra en réalité que deux pour
les 1500 marin galvanisés par
l'importance de leur mission les
services secrets américains par
comparaison fondé estimation beaucoup
plus juste les sous-marins envoyait pour
espionner les japonais reviennent la
pearl harbor deux jours seulement après
l'appareillage de la flotte impériale
midway est transformé en véritable
forteresse hérisset de barbelés de
milliers de sacs de sable
protégé par une centaine d'avions qui
permettent des reconnaissances à longue
distance et une capacité importante de
bombardements
[Musique]
à l'aube du 3 juin une patrouille
aérienne américaine localise les forces
japonaises faisant route sur midway dans
l'après-midi les bombardiers b 17
d'école de l'île et attaque les
bâtiments ennemis sans toutefois les
endommager c'est bombardier vont
cependant jouent un rôle déterminant
dans les heures à venir
à l'aube du lendemain les deux flottes
manoeuvre afin d'être prête à lancer
leurs attaques aériennes
[Musique]
sans connaître la position de la flotte
américaine les japonais commencera
saussure midway une heure plus tard
ayons rhdp les porte-avions nippon d'où
décollent les héros les chasseurs
américains à leur tour font sur leur
cible
il
[Musique]
les avions japonais rencontrent une
forte résistance sur midway une
résistance qui leur coûte cher
la contre attaque américaine contre un
amiral nagumo commandant la force
d'avant-garde à monter un autre assaut
les 108 avions du groupe de réserve
habituellement armé de torpilles sont
cette fois-ci équipés avec des bombes
explosives
ces appareils sont précisément en train
de se réarmer
lorsque les japonais reçoivent les
premiers renseignements sur les navires
américains
renseignements incomplets et qui ne
mentionnerons qu'au plus tard la
présence de portable il faut alors
précipitamment ré équiper les avions
avec des torpilles seule arme adapté à
ce genre de combat à ce moment précis
les porte avions japonais présente la
plus grande confusion bon encombré avion
à pons temps et des collants jamais ils
n'ont été aussi vulnérable
c'est alors qu'apparaissent les
chasseurs américains
[Musique]
il
la première vague d' attaque ne tire pas
un grand avantage de la situation
manquant de coordination dans leur
mouvement
les chasseurs sont malmenés par les
héros qui abattent la presque totalité
de leurs adversaires
[Musique]
la seconde composée cette fois de 54
bombardiers en piqué approche sans avoir
été détectés et touchant quelques
instants trois des quatre porte-avions
lourd le saurions
le gaga est là qu à qui le navire amiral
de nagumo qui a mené le raid contre
pearl harbor les porte-avions prenne feu
les bombes ayant atteint les sodas
carburant et à munitions le quatrième
porte avions japonais le herriot dans
une attaque contre le yorktown mais il
est lui même repéré écoulée par les
bombardiers us ayant perdu quatre porte
avions et une centaine de chasseurs
les japonais sont contraints à la
retraite fortement à varier le yorktown
est pris en remorque mais il est
torpillé deux jours plus tard par un
sous marin japonais dernière victime de
la bataille de midway
[Musique]
les pertes des japonais hamidou et les
contraignent à changer de tactique
ils vont désormais concentrer leurs
efforts sur la consolidation de leurs
positions et la mise en place d'une
barrière d'îles fortifiée ayant pour
objectif la protection de leurs
conquêtes l'île de guadalcanal devient
ainsi leur première base aérienne dans
les îles salomon
elle constitue pour les américains une
menace directe menace à laquelle le
général macarthur et l'amiral nimitz se
prépare à répondre
[Musique]
où
le 7 août 1942 17 mille marines
débarquent par surprise
simultanément à guadalcanal et à toul à
qui ils prennent rapidement le contrôle
de la base mais ont des difficultés à
six mamans guadalcanal devient un
objectif prioritaire pour les deux
adversaires la zone terrestre est pris
sous des tirs intensifs et continue
quant à l'espace maritime de l'archipel
il est rapidement surnommé le carrefour
des torpilles et le fond de ferraille le
secteur présente les plus grands dangers
pour tout bâtiment s'y aventurent
quotidiennement s'y affrontent
américains et japonais bien résolue les
uns comme les autres à fortifier leur
position aux dépens de l'adversaire
[Musique]
le 26 octobre 1942 commence la plus
importante bataille de l'archipel salle
aux mots connus sous le nom de bataille
de santa cruz
elle va opposer d'importants groupes de
porte-avions qui lancent simultanément
leurs appareils à l'assaut les
américains endommage gravement dès le
début de l'engagement de porte avions
japonais de la flotte de l'amiral kondo
les héros réplique à leur tour et
dévastent lantern rise et le hornet et
bientôt torpillé et coulé les
porte-avions des deux camps sont si
endommagé qu'ils vont être tous retirés
du service
[Musique]
je
les combats se poursuivent en novembre
les japonais y perdre deux croiseurs de
bataille et tout comme leurs adversaires
un grand nombre de moyens et petits
bâtiments les japonais sont à bout de
force et relâcher leur pression sur les
îles salomon pour les états unis
guadalcanal représente un pas décisif
dans la guerre du pacifique
[Musique]
celle ci est désormais entre les mains
des forces terrestres des marines
l'affrontement naval se déplace vers
l'ouest ou le 8 novembre 1942
les alliés ont débarqué en afrique du
nord
[Musique]
en réponse les allemands envahissent la
zone libre à toulon craignant de tomber
entre leurs mains la flotte française
aux ordres de l'amiral de laborde se
saborde le 27 novembre au moment même où
les motocyclistes de la wehrmacht arrive
sur les quais du port de guerre
au printemps 1944 la kriegsmarine change
son chiffre secret que la machine enigma
mise au point par les alliés avaient
permis de percer les anglo américains ne
peuvent plus suivre les mouvements des
ou boat qui relance leur attaque avec
succès ou lampre 243 milles tonnes en
mars
à noël la royal navy cool le scharnhorst
l'un des derniers grands navires de
bataille de la kriegsmarine qui
rejoignait la route des convois dans
l'arctique à la même époque les villes
et villages du sud de l'angleterre
commence à voir arriver en masse troupes
et matériels réunis pour ce qui va être
la plus importante opération amphibie de
la guerre le débarquement en normandie
dans les ports s'entassent des milliers
de bâtiments de tonnage
ils vont constituer la plus formidable
armada de l'histoire le 6 juin à l'aube
l approche des côtes de france
[Musique]
alors que 140 mille hommes débarquent en
normandie
les événements se précipitent à nouveau
dans le pacifique
les américains sont passés à l'offensive
et cette fois ci les japonais sont à
leur tour contraint à la riposte
le 11 juin les bâtiments et les avions
us attaque les îles mariannes la
principale base japonaise du secteur
point stratégique déterminant pour les
troupes le mikado celle ci réagissent
vivement à l'assaut des 5e et 7e flotte
américaine transportant 127 milles
hommes et des 800 avions qui attaquent
la base de tignes à nino rota sai panne
et guam un groupe de porte-avions nippon
tente devant les philippines de séparer
la flotte américaine de ses bases
aériennes
[Musique]
l'attak des zéros de l'amiral ozawa
débute le 19 juin mais repéré par les
radars ils sont rapidement dispersés
[Musique]
ce qui échappe tout chasseur sont
abattus par la dessert des porte avions
[Musique]
la seconde vague subi le même sort
les appareils américains bombardent et
mitraillent les basses japonaise
empêchant leurs adversaires de décoller
les sous-marins accroissent les pertes
en coulant deux porte avions
[Musique]
une troisième vague nippone manque
d'attaqué cible mais détruit en vol par
les chasseurs les quatrième et cinquième
vague n'ont pas plus de succès
[Musique]
au crépuscule les américains lancent une
nouvelle contre-attaqué torpille un
troisième porte avions à la fin de la
journée
les japonais ont perdu plus de 400
appareils et la bataille qui sera
surnommé le tir aux pigeons des îles
mariannes plus jamais la marine
impériale ne déploient devant les
américains une force composée de portes
à lyon
[Musique]
désormais libéré de toute attaque
aérienne
la flotte américaine sillonnent le
pacifique disloquant peu à peu le
dispositif des japonais dans les îles
[Musique]
les bombardiers à long rayon d'action
partant des mariannes atteignent
maintenant le territoire japonais lui
même en octobre le général macarthur
commandant en chef des forces us est
bien près de réaliser la promesse faite
au peuple des philippines
malgré leur île et leur ville dévastée
par les bombes les philippines vont
représenter pour les japonais une
dernière opportunité d'endiguer les
succès américains
et pourtant l'état major impérial sait
que sa force de porte avions est
pratiquement inopérantes
surtout depuis la perte de nombreux
pilotes au cours des derniers mois cette
situation dramatique détermine de
stratégies opposées pour les uns
détenteur de la doctrine officielle
le salut repose sur le plan shogo
réunissant la totalité des bâtiments de
guerre japonais subsistant
[Musique]
pour les autres la victoire dépend du
sacrifice librement consenti des pilotes
encore vivant et souvent hâtivement
formés pour qui le culte de l'empereur
et de l'honneur guerrier passe avant
tout les américains vont désormais voir
apparaître les fameux kamikazes dont les
premiers donnent leur vie en écrasant
leurs appareils sur leurs objectifs
américains dans les jours précédant
l'invasion de la hitte et le 18 octobre
1944 24 heures après le débarquement des
marines de macarthur dans le golfe de la
hitte et l'amiral toyoda l'once le
planchot go 1 avec les deux et ce cadre
des amiraux nishimura et pour ida deux
groupes de bataille et une force de
quatre porte avions sous les ordres de
l'amiral
ozawa cette dernière doit jouer le rôle
d'appât dans le golfe de l'été afin
d'attirer la troisième flotte us loin
des îles les groupes de bataille
pourront alors s'approcher de leurs
adversaires et les détruit
la dernière grande bataille navale de la
seconde guerre mondiale commence le 23
octobre les ghettos américains repère la
force de corrida les sous-marins us cool
deux croiseurs et en en dommages un
troisième le lendemain à l'aube les
appareils de la troisième flotte a taclé
ce cadre de nishimura dans la mer deux
sous l'eau quant à la force de coups
rita attaqués sans répit toute la
journée du 24
elle finit par faire demi tour après
avoir été gravement touchés nord
l'amiral ozawa subi un échec sévère en
perdant 56 appareils sur les 76 lancers
contre les américains c'est alors que
ceux ci font l'erreur de séparer leurs
forces en deux la troisième flotte de
l'amiral hals et fonce vers le nord à la
rencontre d'ozawa la septième de
l'amiral kinkaid va affronter seul dans
la nuit du 24 au 25 dans le détroit de
souris gao la flotte de nishimura celle
ci est complètement défaite
c'est alors qu'apparaissent les
bâtiments de l'escadre kourita qui
débouche en force face aux américains
victorieux mais dont les munitions sont
presque épuisés la troisième flotte de
l'amiral hals et arrive à la rescousse
après avoir coulé trois porte avions
japonais au large du cap m gano l'amiral
kourita qui dispose encore de quatre
cuirassé 8 croiseurs et 11 destroyer est
attaqué par la force pourtant beaucoup
plus faible de l'amiral spreng détacher
de la 7e flotte
spring réussite a coulé et a endommagé
plusieurs bâtiments japonais tout en
subissant lui même des pertes sensibles
mais devant la violence de ces attaques
guri tapant se trouvait devant les
portes avions de combat de la troisième
flotte et il fait demi tour
le 25 octobre les kamikazes lancent leur
première opération d'envergure contre
les porte-avions de spring il endommage
gravement le guide bolbec et le kalinin
b est cool le saint lô quant à kourita
il est attaqué le 26 octobre et perd le
croiseur no shiro la bataille de la
était terminée les japonais n'ont pu
atteindre leur objectif et ont perdu
300000 tonnes contre 37 milles aux
américains la victoire de ceci est dû à
la fois la supériorité de leurs forces à
la dispersion des escadres ennemis et à
la confusion de certaines opérations
après la bataille de la hitte et la
marine impériale ne constitue plus une
menace sérieuse
les américains vont pouvoir entreprendre
la libération des philippines et
l'investissement de l'archipel japonais
la bataille du pacifique aura mis en
avant le rôle des porte-avions d'attac
acteurs déterminants d'une nouvelle
stratégie navale